[Music]
the makers the dreamers the scientists
the artists the researchers the
engineers the challengers the game
changers the fearless
today we work the mystic bunkers Secours
of cyberspace and drivers of the
driverless the climate leaders the
energy shapers and front liners of
artificial intelligence today we work
the founders of Newfield the bosses of
brain sciences the smarts behind smart
cities the industry disruptors pioneers
of planetary robotics and architects of
what's next
today we live it breathe it love it
write it rewrite a nail it we have
attack you screw start up start over
tinker imagine and dare today we work
[Applause]
you
in 20 years the earth will have nearly 9
billion people and not enough food so at
carnegie mellon university we're growing
food in a whole new way using artificial
intelligence we analyze plans improve
sustainable growth and get solutions to
farmers
of really smart
we keep the momentum growing there's
work to be done worldwide we do the work
that matters
[Applause]
[Music]
you
have joined the conversation they are
figuring out how most billions of people
in the most efficient way at Carnegie
Mellon University we create
intersections that actually learn so we
all get home faster and safer and with
20% fewer emissions we're not just below
in smoke there's work to be done
worldwide we do the work that matters
[Music]
[Applause]
in a society facing overwhelming
challenges why do we keep making the
same irrational decisions why do we
repeat destructive behaviors at Carnegie
Mellon University as pioneers of
behavioral economics we are advancing
decision making science our distinct
fusion of economics and psychology is
reducing teen pregnancy simplifying
health care and battling economic
injustice we don't just study behavior
we change it we do the work that matters
you
[Applause]
yeah yeah I'm just saying
[Music]
congratulations
Alumni Award honorees who were
recognized at a ceremony this weekend
the procession will begin at 10:15
please be seated by this time it is
important that the track in the aisles
from being clear for the procession
programs for the main ceremony are
available at each stadium entrance
if you require emergency help including
medical assistance please notify a
university police officer or a
commencement volunteer wearing a red
t-shirt in the event of an evacuation
please proceed to the nearest exit
marked by arrows on the video screens to
protect the track-and-field food and
beverages other than water are not
permitted free bottled water is
available in the endzone areas and at
the concession stands under the
bleachers guests link stadium is a
smoke-free environment stadium restrooms
are located near the concession stands
under the bleachers additional restrooms
are available in the Cowan University
Center and in residence halls behind the
commencement stage after the ceremony
has ended please remain in your seats
until the platform group has exited the
stadium
please determine where you need to go
after the ceremony and follow the
appropriate exit route indicated by
signage and on the map in the back of
the printed program shuttle bus service
will be available to take guests to and
from off campus diploma ceremonies refer
to the map in the program for shuttle
stop locations and times Lost and Found
is located in the Cowan University
Center at the information desk
ladies and gentlemen again welcome to
commencement at Carnegie Mellon
University
hey where are you guys
there's power to both of these podiums
[Music]
hey Jason it's Howard
are you on the baby
[Music]
[Applause]
the makers the dreamers the scientists
the artists the researchers the
engineers the challengers the
game-changers with fearless today we
work the mystic bunkers secures of
cyberspace and drivers of the driverless
the climate leaders the energy shapers
and front liners of artificial
intelligence today we work the founders
of new fields the bosses of brain sizes
the smarts behind smart cities the
industry disruptors pioneers of
planetary robotics and architects of
what's next
today we live it breathe it love it
write it rewrite in Eilat we have attack
new group start up start over tinker
imagine ant there today we work
[Applause]
you
you know what keeps us up at night in 20
years the earth will have nearly 9
billion people and not enough food so at
Carnegie Mellon University were growing
food in a whole new way using artificial
intelligence we analyze plans improve
sustainable growth and get solutions to
farmers and thanks to a team of really
smart robots we keep the momentum
growing there's work to be done
worldwide we do the work that matters
you
[Music]
and fewer emissions we're not just below
in smoke there's work to be done
worldwide we do the work that matters
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the procession is
about to begin
please clear all the aisles and take
your seats thank you
she said
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the procession is
about to begin
please clear all the aisles and take
your seats thank you
no one else down
[Applause]
no more on the tracks
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
class of 2018 being led into the stadium
by faculty and Alumni Association Board
members
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
Rosie Spears
[Applause]
[Music]
as faculty marshal it is my honor to
declare the hundred and twenty first
commencement for Carnegie Mellon
University as authorized by the Board of
Trustees to be in session
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the 120 first commencement of
the Carnegie Mellon University my name
is Jim Rohr it's my honor and my
pleasure to introduce you to the Board
of Trustees and a number of other people
this morning as the board chair to all
the students the first group to all the
students who are graduating today let me
begin by congratulating you on your
remarkable achievements this degree
represents you better sit down this
could take a while
this degree represents years of hard
work and self-discipline of discovery
and creativity and problem-solving as
well a Carnegie Mellon degree is a sign
that you've surpassed the high standard
of accomplishment in science art and
ideas and that you are ready to use this
knowledge in your lives and future
professions you're ready to take on the
charge of continuing the long-standing
tradition of doing the work that matters
congratulations to you all
congratulations as well to the friends
and family members coaches mentors
faculty and staff would take great pride
in what these graduates have
accomplished as symbolized by today's
graduation graduation from a demanding
academic institution like Carnegie
Mellon is clearly a team effort
these students couldn't have done it
without you please join me in thanking
the many motivators and supporters who
have helped these graduates succeed
thank you so much for all and with us
today are some faculty and students from
Carnegie Mellon's other locations around
the world I am particularly pleased to
welcome students from the CMU Silicon
Valley campus RCM our CMU Africa program
in Rwanda as well as CMU Australia we're
delighted to have you here today
as members of the Carnegie Mellon
community you are ambassadors of a
distinctive University it was at
Carnegie Mellon that you gained solid
grounding in your major field of study
it was at Carnegie Mellon he
collaborated with people whose
backgrounds are very different than your
own
and it was at Carnegie Mellon that you
discovered new ideas around the world
and new aspects about yourself welcome
to our global community
and the final group for me to welcome
well before I get to that the another
group to welcome as our trustees it's
our job to uphold the university's
values and to support CMU in advancing
its mission to make a transformative
impact on society many trustees are here
today and on the platform this morning
and I would like them to stand and be
recognized now this year as you know
Carnegie Mellon is headed to its
impressive momentum with a number of new
initiatives and partnerships that are
contributing to growth of knowledge
throughout the world we're continuing to
innovate in our teaching and our
learning offering a cross-cutting
interdisciplinary education that meets
our students interests and society's
needs we are pursuing ambitious
initiatives and research and creativity
examining the societal impact of
emerging technologies bringing an
interdisciplinary perspective to better
understand the brain pushing the
boundaries of discovery and foundational
science forging new collaborations in
art music and performance and so much
more
this has truly been a remarkable year
and a great four years for Carnegie
Mellon also the campus is expanding its
spectacular new places including the
first building in the David a temper
quadrangle which creates an unprecedent
opportunity for collaboration and that
will open it this fall this
state-of-the-art facility is designed to
break the mold of education the
educational experience adding to the
vibrancy and synergy of our campus and
our ecosystem now I know this graduating
class won't be here for the opening of
that building but that's actually a good
thing because that means you'll have the
opportunity to come back and we'll share
a coffee and hopefully discuss what new
things are happening
Carnegie Mellon so welcome back you have
to come back to the temper quad nice
trustees it's our job to uphold the
university's values to support the
university and advancing its mission and
I think it's very important that you can
see that reflected in the Tepper
building now this exciting time at
Carnegie Mellon University were
delighted to have a truly visionary
leader at the helm and doctor Farnum
Shahani and dr. johan even many of you
know dr. johan ian as he has previously
had an enormous impact at CMU having
served previously as provost and chief
academic officer and now he's the
Carnegie Mellon's newly appointed
president and exactly the right leader
for this university as at this
extraordinary moment in time at this
time it's my great privilege to
introduce the tenth president of
Carnegie Mellon University dr. Farnham
Jolyon
[Applause]
good morning everyone it's so wonderful
to be with you this morning before I
start I have a question for our 2018
graduates are you excited to be here
that was pretty good with the Chairman's
permission I'm gonna ask that question
again the 2018 graduates are you excited
to be here that's much better much
better
let me also offer my congratulations to
the CMU class of 2018 I would also like
to extend a warm welcome to your
families and loved ones who share in
your achievements and likewise I wish to
congratulate the faculty and staff who
have guided you along the way
commencement is always a special day for
our community and this occasion and this
class is particularly special for me
personally not only your degree is the
first one that I will confer as
president of Carnegie Mellon what we
also started our CMU journey around the
same time you're the first class that I
have observed all the way from
convocation to commencement
it's been a thrilling and honor to watch
you grow into CMU alumni today we're all
gathered to celebrate your
accomplishment over the past few years
you have worked hard to get here and we
are so proud to salute you today let me
express my deep appreciation to CMU's
Board of Trustees chair mr. Jim Rohr Jim
your energy vision and leadership has
made you one of the great business
leaders of our generation and your
stewardship at CMU has allowed us to
plot a strong future Jim thank you very
much for all that you do for Carnegie
Mellon I also wish to add my thanks to
all the members of the board of trustees
of Carnegie Mellon for placing their
trust in me and for their service for
their passion and commitment on behalf
of the University thank you very much
close to you at this point I would like
to recognize a number of alumni groups
in the attendance today the 2018
Distinguished Alumni Award honorees and
of course our legacy families Carnegie
Mellon is a bluff tradition in so many
families and we're always pleased to see
successive generations of family members
attending CMU all CMU alumni here today
are specially designated by the blue
stoles they're wearing we're happy to
see so many of you back home with us
Woodall
I'm getting there Woodall CMU alumni in
attendance please stand to be recognized
please stand it's wonderful to have you
here and I hope our new graduates
continue this tradition and return
commit to commencement in the future our
110,000 alumni in hundred and thirty
countries all well represented in the
university community by Carnegie Mellon
Alumni Association it is now my pleasure
to introduce the Alumni Association
Board president Debbie u Dietrich
College of Humanities and social science
class of 1989 while she was earning her
bachelor's degree in technical writing
at Carnegie Mellon she was a reporter
for the Tartan was active in the pre-law
Society now a partner at the firm of
Gallagher Sharpe in Cleveland Ohio
debbie has been an active volunteer for
the Northeast Ohio alumni network since
2007 having served previously as Network
president
Debbie joined the AAB in 2010 and began
her term nearly two years ago she has
been an outstanding representative for
all CMU alumni as her term as president
concludes this summer
I want to thank Debbie for her
enthusiastic and steadfast leadership
these past two years please join me in
extending a warm welcome to Debbie you
Debbie
Thank You president Jahan en it is such
an honor to be here to celebrate today
with all of you as an alum Carnegie
Mellon will always have a special place
in our lives
my Carnegie Mellon story began before I
was even born after my parents
immigrated to the United States they
eventually made their way to Pittsburgh
so that my dad could pursue his Graduate
Studies here at Carnegie Mellon so for
me like my CNU story began then when I
returned to Carnegie Mellon to begin
forging my own career path I'm sure the
campus looked very different from the
days when my dad roamed the halls
however the passion and dreams of all
those here at Carnegie Mellon were still
the same while I in my immensely
appreciate and value the education and
the experience as a student here in many
ways as an alum Carnegie Mellon has
taken on a different meaning since
graduating I've shown my pride in our
alma mater through different ways
including volunteering as well as
celebrating the achievements and
contributions of our fellow alums at the
annual alumni Awards I also credit
Carnegie Mellon with fueling my
continued passion for learning the CMU
Alumni Association provides
opportunities for us to continue to
learn as well as learn from our faculty
and our fellow alums so you see my
Carnegie Mellon story began decades ago
but continues to this day and into the
future
so as you begin as you are preparing to
bring all that you've learned here at
Carnegie Mellon as a student out into
the world
you all know where your CMU's story
began and as you turn the page and enter
the next chapter you will continue to
thirst for knowledge you will continue
to seek opportunities to build on your
professional skills
professional network of colleagues and
friends as well as seek out
opportunities for career growth know
that Carnegie Mellon is here for you
Carnegie Mellon provides those
opportunities for you to network with
your fellow alums for you to continue to
learn and for you to learn about all the
exciting ways that seem you continues to
impact the world around us I encourage
you to show your pride in our alma mater
to stay connected with the University
and to continue to build on your unique
Carnegie Mellon story on behalf of the
Carnegie Mellon Alumni Association and
board
we welcome you into the global alumni
community of 110,000 strong best wishes
and congratulations class of 2018
at this time I'm delighted to introduce
this year's the student speaker Kevin
Wayne Zach
today Kevin is graduating with
university honors from the Dietrich
College of Humanities and Social
Sciences earning a bachelor's degree in
cognitive science with a minor in
software engineering
Kevin is both an exemplary scholar and a
passionate student leader a member of
the Dietrich College Dean's List he was
inducted into the Sakai international
Honor Society in psychology he has been
a resident assistant community advisor
cabinet minute member in student
government and a leader in the Greek
community also serving as vice president
of community standards for
Interfraternity Council this past winter
Kevin was awarded the CMU Greek role
model award for excellence in
scholarship leadership service and
lifelong friendship Kevin also served as
chair and director of event logistics
and head of marketing for the Pittsburgh
donut dash
[Music]
the annual citywide event has raised
more than 570 thousand in four years to
support ALS research and is among the
largest Greek plant tropic event in the
nation after graduating Kevin will take
his many talents to Washington DC
working for Deloitte as a consultant for
the federal government please join me in
an enthusiastic round of applause for
the class of 2018 student speaker Kevin
Wayne Zach Kevin
Thank You president John Ian for the
kind introduction I've had no greater
honor in my life than to be standing
here today graduating with all of you
and our time here we've seen a lot of
change Skibo cafe has become waiting 30
minutes for a sandwich free stones have
become you see stones and we have like a
bajillion more buildings on campus now
than we did before
all of this change marks the end of a
long journey of education for many of us
to those of you continuing on to even
more school well good luck
when I think back to freshman year
between all of the vote Ellie's pizza
that I ordered the hundreds of times I
walk down Morewood Avenue and the few
tipsy trips down dealer
[Applause]
someone somewhere told me something that
I don't think I'll ever forget
they said the years that I spend at
Carnegie Mellon are going to be the most
difficult of my life but that everything
after is gonna be easy well at that
point I bet you could guess what I was
thinking yes all I have to do is write a
few lines of code and the Silicon Valley
will be knocking on my door right well
the main point of that completely flew
over my head because I didn't know what
it meant
did it mean that Carnegie Mellon was
going to work me just hard enough that
everything was to be easy in comparison
or that I was going to become so smarter
that I could solve any and every problem
well for years we have worked hard to
achieve our goals now I believe that our
time at CMU is difficult because there
are lessons that we learn and goals that
we have that require us to commit and it
is this commitment that Foster's that
Carnegie Mellon spirit of putting our
hearts into our work we committed to
learning these lessons from and with
each other fellow students have taught
me that it is important not to be a
voice for others rather we should use
the voice that we have to bring others
into the conversation I learned that
while we are capable of doing great
things the most important thing that any
of us can be is a great friend we've
learned these lessons and had these
successes because we attended Carnegie
Mellon during wild and historic times in
which it has become clear that diversity
is our strength
we accomplished more when we stand
together
and we committed to doing work that
manifests these lessons I've seen this
commitment in the plains that CMU
students have sent to Puerto Rico in the
gatherings that we've had at the fence
and the late-night meetings in my
fraternity I've seen it in the beautiful
expressions of self at community collage
and in the kind actions of you my fellow
students as we support each other
through homeworks and projects that we
absolutely should have started at least
a week ago in order to learn these
lessons in order to do this work we
needed to commit to being tenacious and
to being brave I've seen my pr7 street
tenacity while building many buildings
that go up for only a weekend while
raising record-breaking amounts of money
for local charities and in working with
our administration to improve the
student experience I know I had to be
brave freshman year when I called my mom
and I had to convince her that cognitive
science was just as lucrative as civil
engineering making it here today for
many of us is an act of bravery itself
see I have 100% faith that if we go out
into our communities and keep with us
this spirit that Carnegie Mellon has
given us we are going to continue to
learn and change the world people
sitting in this stadium right now are
going to save our environment when
Oscars and Toni's create art that
changes people's lives some of us are
going to become doctors disrupt
industries cure cancer become the
elected leaders of tomorrow and make
this world a better place
if we can continue to learn from those
who have come before us and teach those
who follow we are going to craft a
future where compassion fuels innovation
and at the very least yet just as
important each one of us has it in us to
be a role model for our younger
generations and the fruits of our effort
they might not be seen immediately
maybe not for five years or ten years or
more but it will still require us to
commit and who knows maybe life after
Carnegie Mellon is going to be easy
maybe it won't be me but at least now we
kind of know what we're doing so while
we have all forged our own paths to
arrive at commencement today we have
converged for what is likely the last
time I challenge our class to charge out
into the world take what you've learned
at Carnegie Mellon and engage in the
pursuit of something greater than
ourselves and don't do it alone and
never waver in your commitment or in
your tenacity because I know we can and
because there are a few others better
equipped to do so right now than us
thank you so much for allowing me to
speak today and I am so excited to see
what we are all going to achieve thank
you
[Applause]
remind me not to follow Kevin after if
speech that he gives Kevin thank you
very much for those inspiring words and
best wishes for your continued success
once again please join me in
congratulating and thanking Kevin for
his speech today and now we're honored
to present special doctor's degree to
individuals who have had extraordinary
impact in the arts business science
scholarship and society recipients of
these honorary degrees have reached
preeminent levels of distinction in
their fields advancing knowledge
enriching culture and improving the
human condition to present these
honorary degrees I would like to
introduce dr. Laurie Weingarten who has
been serving as our interim provost
during the past year by the way I should
tell you that it's CMU tradition that
the Provost is responsible for the
weather
thank you dr. Weingarten
Loree a CMU faculty member since 1989 is
the sired professor of organizational
behavior and theory in the Tepper School
of Business Laurie thank you for taking
this critical position and for all that
you have done to advance the scholarly
mission of the University dr. Cohn
weingartz will present each candidate
and cite two achievements that merit
dishonor then all candidates will
receive together their degrees and their
doctoral wedding Laurie please join us
[Applause]
Ted Danson after graduating from the CMU
School of Drama in 1972 you rose to
stardom as an iconic television star
best known for playing bartender Sam
alone in the NBC sitcom Cheers
the show ran for 11 years winning three
Emmys for Best Comedy Series and earning
you two Emmys for Outstanding Lead Actor
in a comedy as well as two Golden Globes
but your career has only accelerated
since then with celebrated TV hits like
Becker damages Curb Your Enthusiasm
Fargo and CSI and film credits including
three men and a baby and Steven
Spielberg's masterful Saving Private
Ryan away you've currently play a
surprisingly likeable demon on the
quirky and beloved NBC show the good
place and will appear in the film hearts
beat loud' this summer an award-winning
environmentalist you co-founded the
American oceans campaign to increase
awareness of the dangers created by oil
spills offshore development and sewage
in 2011 you authored the book Oceania
are endangered
oceans and what we can do to save them
and Oceania the largest international
ocean conservation organization recently
awarded you a Lifetime Achievement Award
Ted Danson for your outstanding
contributions in television and film and
for your efforts to protect and preserve
our oceans Carnegie Mellon is honored to
award you the honorary degree of Doctor
of Fine Arts
well shoppi Goldwasser please come
forward
Shafi goldwasser you took your degree in
Applied Mathematics from the CMU Mellon
College of Science and used it to launch
a career is one of the world's most
prolific and highly decorated computer
scientists into that in 2012
you received the Association for
computing Machinery's Turing award the
highest honor in computer science for
your lasting technical contributions to
the field your discoveries laid the
foundation for modern theoretical
cryptography taking it from a field of
trial and error experimentation to a
mathematical science your trailblazing
work has established standard
definitions of security for encryption
and digital signatures as a computer
science professor and director of the
simons Institute for the theory of
computing at UC Berkeley you are a
two-time winner of the Goodell prize for
outstanding papers in theoretical
computer science
you're also a role model for women and
have been honored by the Association for
computing Machinery's grace Murray
hopper award and the Athena award for
women in computer science a member of
the National Academy of Sciences the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
and the National Academy of Engineering
you've also been recognized
internationally by prestigious academies
in Israel Russia and the United Kingdom
Shafi goldwasser for your unparalleled
contributions to the field of computer
science Carnegie Mellon is honored to
award you the honorary Doctor of Science
and Technology
well ADA Ionut please come forward
ada UNF you have been internationally
recognized for your groundbreaking
studies in the structure and function of
the ribosome in 2009 you won the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry
becoming the first woman in 45 years to
receive this award
your pioneering research used x-ray
crystallography to uncover how the
ribosome functions at the atomic level
to create proteins for various cellular
functions these discoveries not only
advanced our understanding of human
biochemistry but all it was also vital
to the development of antibiotics early
in your career you came to Carnegie
Mellon as a postdoctoral researcher and
CMU's Mellon College of Science and
we're delighted to welcome you back
today almost 50 years later you would
later return to Israel where you open
the country's first structural biology
laboratory today you continue to produce
important work in protein biosynthesis
as the kimmel professor of structural
biology and director of the Kimmelman
Center a biometric biomolecular
structure and assembly at the Weizmann
Institute of Science in Israel in
addition to the Nobel you've won
numerous honors including the Israel
prize the Albert Einstein world award
for excellence and the era's prize for
peace Haiti
ADA yonas for your historical
contributions to science Carnegie Mellon
is honored to award you the honorary
degree of Doctor of Science and
Technology will David Tepper please come
forward David Tepper you are not only an
influential voice in the global
financial community you are also one of
Carnegie Mellon's most ardent champions
at CMU where you earned your MBA in 1982
you laid the foundation for a truly
legendary career in finance business and
philanthropy after launching your career
on Wall Street you founded Appaloosa
management in 1993 and developed the
hedge fund into one of the most
successful in the world consistently
outperforming industry peers for the
past 25 years
the son of a school teacher you have
also demonstrated a passion for
education and its power to create and
nurture Future Leaders you have
contributed visionary leadership as a
CMU trustee you're pro your profound
generosity has propelled our business
goal named in your honor to even greater
success your most recent gift will
reinvent when T first century education
at CMU through the creation of the David
a temper quadrangle the new home for the
tougher School of Business and a
transformative new campus hub that will
open this fall
in your own words you have indeed
learned it earned it and returned it did
David a temper for your exceptional
leadership in business your passion for
education and your commitment to
philanthropy Carnegie Mellon is honored
to award you the honorary degree of
Doctor of business practice Ted Danson
Shafi goldwasser awed Jornet David
Tepper by virtue of the authority
granted to me by the Board of Trustees I
hereby confer those honorary degrees
upon you with all the rights honors
privileges and responsibilities
pertaining thereto congratulations
ladies and gentlemen the 2018 honorary
degree recipients at Carnegie Mellon
University
[Applause]
it is now my distinct pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker business
leader investment icon philanthropist
business school alum University trustee
and Carnegie Mellon champion David Allen
pepper
oh I have several pages to read David
through his legendary business savvy and
investment expertise Davis David has
earned an unrivaled reputation as one of
the most successful hedge fund managers
in the world but he is equally well
known for his passion for philanthropy
his belief in the power of higher
education and of course his exceptional
service and generosity to his alma mater
Carnegie Mellon University David grew up
not too far from here in the Stanton
Heights neighborhood of Pittsburgh the
middle of three children I should just
add so that David's mother Roberta is
here with us would you please
acknowledge Roberta
he went to the University of Pittsburgh
for his undergraduate degree in
economics before receiving his MBA in
1982 from our graduate school of
industrial administration it wasn't
called at upper school back there I know
in 1985 he was recruited by Goldman
Sachs as a credit analyst and within
just six months he became the head
trader under newly established
high-yield bond group this was the first
clue that David was a force to be
reckoned with on Wall Street in 1993 the
same year the web entered the public
domain
David established Appaloosa management
and over the last 25 years has built an
impressively consistent record of high
returns Appaloosa currently has
approximately 17 billion under
management and has yielded gross returns
close to 40 percent per year
over the past 20 years through the David
Tepper Charitable Foundation his
philanthropy has expanded opportunities
for education helped to fight hunger and
homelessness and provided much-needed
disaster relief he has generously
donated a total of 125 million to
Carnegie Mellon University
including naming and endowing The Temper
School of Business where he serves as
the school's Business Board of Advisors
and in 2013 his most recent
transformative gift enabled the creation
of his state of the art facility on the
new David a temper quadrangle scheduled
to open this fall at at more than 300
thousand square feet this building will
serve as the new home for the Tempur
School of Business as well as a major
hub for collaboration innovation
creativity and entrepreneurship at
Carnegie Mellon The Temper quad will
create unprecedented opportunities to
break new barriers and to work toward
new discoveries new technologies new
businesses and new forms of expression
as our institution continues to grow and
build for an evolving future the Tempur
quad is the physical realization of a
new model for 21st century research and
education and it will transform the CMU
experience for generations of students
to come David has given so much to
Carnegie Mellon
to our nation and the world and were
delighted to welcome him back to campus
to share his wisdom with the class of
2018 please join me in extending a warm
welcome to David a tapper David
good morning class of 2018 did I have a
speech here nice binder I think I might
read it later but I just a couple
observations first that I didn't think
about before back over there I was
standing next to Kevin he's right there
and we were talking his voice was
shaking my voice was shaking we were
both nervous as heck I was gonna say
another word but I'm told I'm not
supposed to say those words today so
we're coming out and we're we're there
and we're both kind of like shaky a
little bit and then Kevin Kevin start
straightening up he starts getting the
strength about it and he says I'm
starting to fill it these are my people
my people so we say that he's put it out
some friends over there we said hottest
family over there his mother Lauren who
told me a couple stories about Kevin
that I'm not gonna say now went up the
aisle shaked a few hands there set a
little an wall high n wall yeah good to
see you over there and you know Kevin
just came up here and gave the most
fantastic speech and I'm thinking crap I
can't not be as good because I got
something I gotta read and it's twice as
long and I can't just kind of ad-lib it
and then I was thinking well you know
what you guys Kevin's family you guys
out here students please all you guys
here you're my people too
okay you're my people too
you're Carnegie Mellon people carmely
Carnegie Mellon students Carnegie Mellon
graduates my people so help me out today
I need help
so because I got to read this and I
don't know how it's gonna go so we're
gonna see all right let me start by
thank you for him for that kind
introduction for the kind introduction I
got to get this kind of right here I
don't know what I'm gonna do and for his
leadership of Carnegie Mellon as you
know for in him this place means the
world to me it really is a treasure
there's no other University that bring
together business where are you
thank you the arts
[Music]
the humanities the sciences and the
social sciences the way CMU does good to
see you thanks also to my fellow
trustees to my fellow alumni who are
over the place here engineering I
[Applause]
apologize they told me not to leave the
podium but I don't like I'm sorry about
that and engineering can I get a hardhat
up here this big all right
I cannot lost my place but what's right
thanks also to my fellow trustees my
fellow alumni and most of all to you
guys whose students and to your parents
a special thanks to my family and
friends who are here today and of course
to my 86 year old mom I think she's over
there hi mom when you're over there
someplace mom where are you mom
someplace over there I think my mom's a
little happy and proud today but my mom
sometimes can be a pain in the butt and
I'm sure your parents can be too but
there's nobody on earth I owe more to
and there's nobody on earth you owe more
to than your parents in life in life you
should recognize your parents so let's
take a moment and thank them
and last but not least I want to
congratulate and thank my fellow
honorary doctors adda where are you at
it that is a very funny lady I got to
tell you this whoever's gonna listen to
her later a Nobel Prize what she also
has a Nobel Prize
it's a side thing Shafi Goldwasser a
touring Award winner and a guy used to
watch on TV when I was younger not that
much younger an Emmy Award winner Ted
Danson they're catching up to your wife
Ted his wife has a couple doctors more
than him so but he's catching up it's
amazing what you can find out by talking
to people a good thing to listen now
after to thank you so I think I'm
supposed to start a speech here and
preparing I was given advice from
professional speech writers and public
relations people and of course my
children they all told me not to be too
controversial and try to be proper
let me apologize to all them in advance
sorry guys not gonna happen I also
prepared by listening to some of the
best commencement speeches of all time
many were by actors somewhere by
politicians all were delivered with
eloquence and in a professional manner
to all those of attendance to all those
in attendance if you were expecting to
hear a professional speech today you may
be at the wrong commencement but what I
can promise what I can promise you is as
much honesty and personal personal life
experiences as I can muster I think
people's life's are really combination
of different lace for you students it's
been a life you had before college with
your parents and the life you had at
college now and the life you're about to
embark on
I'm sure some of you I'm sure some of
you who have overcome incredible
adversity all of you have had and I can
promise you all have challenges
disappointments and triumphs I'm no
different on the trumpet trial side this
has been a hell of a week a kid from the
streets of Pittsburgh who had a worked
his way through college at Pitt and grad
school which sleet CMU just got an
honorary Doctor and is giving a
commencement speech at this university a
kid a kid who could afford to go to an
NFL game I kid
I kid who sorry about that a kid who
couldn't afford to go to an NFL game
until well went to his 20s is on the
verge of getting the NFL's approval to
buy the Carolina Panthers not too shabby
but believe me it did start out that way
I grew up I grew up in a working-class
neighborhood of standing heights in the
city of Pittsburgh
we played touch football on the street
and tackle football in a nearby cemetery
we try to not hit the gravestones the
cell phone of the day was mom calling up
the street to say dinner was ready my
dad like a lot of dads had a worked 60
hours weeks just to make ends meet but
he taught me a couple things a couple
important lessons first always think
about charity and those less fortunate
he came even when my family didn't have
enough and another lesson he used to ask
us who do you treat better the president
or the garbage man do you guys know the
answer
garbage man I'm talking just generally
not about any specific president by the
way
garbage man corporis man is rubbish man
may be the right answer because somebody
just got to take your trash everyday
right and if he doesn't take your trash
or really trouble but actually the
answer is you treat them both both the
same all men and women and women deserve
to be treated equally and with respect
[Applause]
despite these good things about my dad
he had a bad side too
he was physically abusive to me I'm sure
it was a cycle that he got from his
father and his father got from his
father in my young life
there was nothing more terrifying there
was no greater adversity but I pray to
God that I would never be the same to my
children and I'm proud to say and what I
view as a greatest accomplishment of my
life I broke that cycle
thank you now I'm shaking high school
was at an inner-city school called
Peabody was about half white and half
african-american there really was a lot
of tension at the school between us at
the school back then and between the
different high schools things were so
bad between Westinghouse high school and
Peabody I think it's now called a Barack
Obama high that when we played each
other in football it was in front of
empty stands to keep people from
fighting it was rough there was actually
no grass on the field it was dirt rocks
and they used to oil down the field to
keep the dust from coming up true story
one field goal post was against the
skull the other field goal post was
against a fence if you ran out of the
endzone you had real problems so I
played a little football in high school
when I was also in school place CFA but
money being short I had to work my first
job application was at McDonald's I got
turned down I did I think it was because
I had an oversize afro wouldn't be a
problem today actually what had to take
it off was so freaking hot up here I
gotta tell you but I did get a job as a
short-order cook in a deli I also sold
knife door-to-door and it was a union
work in a bakery after high school I
went to the University of Pittsburgh
where is it down there okay where I ate
at the dirty Oh the original hotdog
anybody at the original hotdog France
you like the French fries better you
like the hot dogs better french fries
raise your head hot dogs all right
french fries win the day Eddie the dirty
Oh had a girlfriend or two and worked at
the fine arts library and got an honors
degree in economics
after Pitt I worked at a bank for a
little and then came to Koenig Nagy
Mellon for my MBA
even though his hard work I actually
loved this place it was also the
foundation for everything I've done
professionally since then this paid
place this place gave me the tools I
needed to be successful it really did
I'm not kidding
well when I graduated I kind of liked
markets and investments so I tried to
get a job with Goldman Sachs but they
rejected me didn't get a job there we'll
come back to Goldman Sachs a little
later so after I got my MBA I made an
unusual choice at the time I went to
work for Republic Steel that wasn't a
great time for steel but I know I would
have be exposed to a lot and I really
wanted to learn about three months after
I got the Republic still they gave a
seven percent across-the-board pay cut
they cut all my business gold buddies oh
my ghostess of school friends called me
up and said great choice Thep in two
years we probably still had to merge to
avoid bankruptcy but it was a great
choice and in those two years as they
were trying to save the company we did
more finance skills than it had at its
previous 100 year history and I learned
from each one of them there's a lesson
here in life in life get all the
experience you can while you're young go
for the experience versus the paycheck
that kind of experience got me a job at
a mutual fund specializing to distressed
companies and eventually in the door of
Goldman Sachs we're in a short time
because my previous job experience and
cutting it's things cutting it's things
I learned to CMU I advanced quickly and
became the head trader and Goldman's
junk desk that gave me more status and I
knew at the time but I really wanted was
to become a partner I was up a partner
for a few times but never made it one of
the reasons was I had to refuse a
powerful partners request the stories
this
the partner has started a new fund to
invest in bankrupt companies and I was
supposed to make the trades for him he
was also the partner for the told our
restricted list that's the list of
companies where you might have some
conflicts are some sensitive information
he asked me to buy a company that he had
just removed from the restricted list
that day that day it didn't seem right
in fact I went to our legal department
it told them what was going on they said
it would be okay after a lot of
back-and-forth but it's still to feel
right to me
so I refused again I didn't get fired
but when I came up for partner I got
shot down and I was incredibly upset but
you know what you know what it turned
out alright because I didn't end up a
partner at Goldman Sachs
I started starting my own company 25
years ago in 1993 called Appaloosa and
ended up doing something that was a lot
more fun and made my life better in so
many ways in life in life do what's
right really do what's right and it
won't hurt you
just keep your priorities straight you
know I keep saying in life but really as
I said before there are many lies I've
had an incredible life from humble
beginnings I've raised three great kids
have a woman I love I've had a
successful business career and
incredible philanthropic endeavors and
now I am speaking to you as a newly
named doctorate and I am on the verge of
being named an NFL owner
you guys you guys used to this is okay
to say guys do this girls carry guys
that are just guys girls whatever you
students sorry you had a life with your
parents then a life at CMU and you're
going to have a few more lifes right now
like I did I think I'll right now you
all have negative balance sheets but you
have so much upside you all have great
opportunities ahead
don't let anyone anyone tell you
different you live in what was is and
always will be the land of opportunity
and the most and the greatest and most
generous country in the world remember
remember this last thing when all you
become successful remember to give back
give back god bless all of you
god bless see em you and god bless
america
thank you
David I'm sure everybody in the audience
including me are incredibly inspired by
your words and your story and your
example it's now my pleasure to
recognize the faculty members who have
recently accepted emeritus status like
all of our educators these distinguished
individuals are scholars scientists
artists and above all teachers they've
left an indelible mark on this
University through their support and
encouragement that they've provided to
our students and through the legacy of
exceptional scholarship those of maritai
who are present this morning please
stand as I read your name and then
please hold your applause until I've
read all their names the first is a
Moroccan professor of architecture
Oh can't my apologies and welcome and
good to see you thank you David Claire
the Walter Van Dyke Bingham professor of
psychology rock Robert kraut the Herbert
a Simon professor of human-computer
interaction
Bruce crow professor professor of
Electrical and Computer Engineering and
Natalie Jose Asst professor of music and
James Russ professor of physics please
join me in thanking all of Carnegie
Mellon's maritai faculty for their
service and dedication to the University
I'd Lao let I'd now like to recognize
those faculty members who were recently
honored with the title of university
professor being appointed a university
professor is one of the highest honors
that a CMU faculty member can receive
receiving this rank confers both honor
and obligation on to its recipients and
denotes a legacy of exceptional
contribution to education artistic
creativity and research this prestigious
group includes faculty from all of
Carnegie Mellon's colleges and schools
I'm pleased to announce that four
faculty members have joined this
illustrious ranks this year nominated
and recommended by academic leaders and
university professors and provoked
promoted to university professor by
president Jahan Ian and myself as I read
your name please stand and be recognized
the first newly appointed University
professor is Roberta klasky the Charles
J Queen and junior professor of
psychology professor of psychology and
human-computer interaction
I'm also pleased to congratulate Cindy
Lamar Oh professor of lighting School of
Drama and School of Architecture please
join me and also congratulating oh it's
Lowell Taylor with us tonight well I
mentioned Lowell Taylor HJ Heinz the
third professor of economics and finally
our fourth newly appointed University
professor Larry Wasserman UPMC professor
of statistics and data science who could
not join us this evening congratulations
to our new University professors we're
now going to begin the event you've been
waiting for the formal conferral of
degrees on all the students who have
duly completed the requirements of their
programs to the satisfaction and
approval of our faculty members the
commencement program lists each
student's degree in areas of study which
will be called out and celebrated at the
departmental diploma ceremonies I
encourage families and friends to look
and listen beyond just your own
graduates listing to get a sense of the
unique educational environment at
Carnegie Mellon the many unique
interdisciplinary pursuits minors and
areas of expertise that makes this
institution so distinctive and our
graduating class so exceptional I want
to begin by acknowledging the
achievements of this groups of this
year's group of doctoral students and
doctoral candidates these outstanding
scholars received their academic hoods
at a special ceremony yesterday
afternoon in earning their doctorates
they've made a commitment to the life of
scholarly pursuits and have reaffirmed
the importance and prominence of
Carnegie Mellon as one of the nation's
premier research universities I'd like
to invite the doctor degree candidates
to please rise and be recognized
be seated
in addition we're pleased today to
officially confirm atcha lers degrees to
students graduating from Carnegie Mellon
University Qatar these students earned
degrees from the Dietrich College the
Mellon College of Science and the School
of Computer Science in The Temper School
of Business at this time I'd like to
recognize the Dean of Carnegie Mellon
University Qatar Michael trick we're
delighted we're delighted to
congratulate Mike on completing his
first year as Dean and Mike thank you
all that you've done for CMU q in
keeping it on a course of continued
excellence ok candidates I'm now going
to give you a little bit of direction on
how this is gonna work we're gonna ask
all degree candidates from each College
to stand and be recognized as you're
called upon by your Dean and then when
all the schools and colleges have been
recognized the president will then ask
all students to stand again at which
time he'll formally confer your degrees
so when you Dean's calling you I want to
hear your enthusiasm okay are you with
me yeah all right okay if not just
follow the person next to you I'll be
good
I'm now going to call on the Dean of
each school in college to present its
candidates for degrees president Jahan
Ian please join me at the podium to
begin with I want to recognize James
Garrett Dean of the College of
Engineering
we'll all of the candidates from the
college of engineering please rise
enthusiastically
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president mr. president upon the
recommendation of our faculty I have the
honor of presenting the bachelor's
master's and doctoral degree candidates
from the College of Engineering
will the new college of engineering
graduates please be seated I will now
recognize the Dean of the College of
Fine Arts Dan Martin
[Applause]
we'll all of my talented passionate
tenacious wicked smart and incredibly
creative candidates please rise that's
it on the recommendation of our faculty
I have the honor of presenting the
bachelor master's degree and doctoral
degree candidates from the number one
College of Fine Arts in the country
[Applause]
well the College of Fine Arts candidates
please be seated I will now recognize
the Dean of the Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences
Richard shyness well all the candidates
from the Mariana brown Dietrich College
of Humanities and Social Sciences the
number one humanities and social
sciences colleges on the planet please
rise
[Applause]
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
presenting to you bachelor's master's
and doctoral candidates from the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences please sit I will now
recognize the Dean of the Heinz College
ramaya Krishna will all the candidates
from the Heinz College of Information
Systems in public policy please rise
who's the president upon the
recommendation of our faculty I have the
honor of presenting the Masters and
doctoral degree candidates from the
Heinz College will the new Heinz College
graduates please be seated and I will
now call on the Dean of the Mellon
College of Science
Rebekah Dortch will the candidates from
the Mellon College of Science the best
college of science and the cosmos please
rise and make some noise
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
presenting the bachelor's master's and
doctoral three candidates from the
Mellon College of Science
congratulations you guys you did a great
job
I will now now call on the Dean of the
school of computer science
Andrew Moore we'll all the people
responsible for creating the next phase
of the human race please rise
upon the recommendation of our faculty I
had the honor of presenting the
bachelor's master's and doctoral degree
candidates from the school of computer
science listen and last but not least I
will call on the Dean of The Temper
School of Business Robert Damon okay
look this is your shot at it now you've
got the school's major benefactor here
don't disappoint well all of the
candidates from The Temper School of
Business please rise with enthusiasm
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our distinguished faculty I have the
honor of presenting the bachelor's
master's and doctoral degree degree
candidates from The Temper School of
Business congratulations with a temper
school of graduates please be seated
[Music]
[Applause]
Carnegie Mellon is proud to lead the
world in interdisciplinary research and
education and nurtures several
university-wide inter college and joint
degree programs within our University on
behalf of all of the deans and program
directors I'll now present the
candidates for degrees from these
special programs will all the bachelor's
master's and doctoral candidates and our
interdisciplinary programs please rise
mr. president upon the recommendation of
our faculty I have the honor of
presenting these candidates who
represent all that is wonderful about
our university from our university-wide
inter-college and joint degree programs
I'm gonna ask all of you to remain
standing and I'd like to invite students
from all the colleges to stand once
again for the official conferral of
degrees by president johan Ian there we
go are you ready by virtue of the
authority granted to me by the Board of
Trustees I hereby confer these degrees
upon these candidates with all the
rights honors privileges and
responsibilities pertaining thereto I am
pleased to join the entire university
community in congratulating the
graduating class of 2018
we'll all the new bachelor's master's
and a doctoral graduates of Carnegie
Mellon University please be seated
once again congratulations I am
immensely proud to stand before you
today the Carnegie Mellon University
graduating class of 2018 this afternoon
I see thousands of new graduates ready
to turn their passion creativity and
fearlessness into a lifetime of societal
impact personal fulfillment and
professional success during your time
here you have each made an indelible
mark on this community
you learned deeply and daily inside and
outside the classroom you built a
community rooted in empathy inclusion
and respect forging connections that
will last a lifetime you engage in
creative collaborations with faculty
students across the campus you embraced
our celebration of Carnegie Mellon's
fiftieth anniversary and you each found
ways to be CMU founders your community
service and engagement raise funds and
brought awareness to societal issues you
also shined a light on the ways that our
own community could do better
you brought passion and thoughtfulness
to everything you did whether it was
building a Hyperloop or a moon arc you
can co-op it's okay
shining your talent onstage in a gallery
or through a hackathon creating new
frontiers in artificial intelligence
transition design or material science
[Applause]
and yes even advocating to free the you
see stones you're gonna have to tell
your parents what that means later okay
you were instrumental in attracting a
record enrollment of women and the
largest number of application in the
history of this university through your
example you made a community others want
to join I want to thank you for making
CMU better now it's your time to unleash
your extraordinary energy and skills on
the vast opportunities ahead of you it's
tradition for the President to deliver a
charge to the graduates at the
commencement ceremony one final set of
instructions for how to maximize the
power of your newly minted CMU degree in
reality you won't find a better example
for living CMU's mission and values than
the career of our keynote speaker David
Tappan
so listen to everything that he said
so knowing that I stand alone I alone
stand between you and graduating parties
I will keep my charge brief the
incomparable CMU professor herb Simon
once said we're not spectators of the
future we are actors of the future you
may be wondering how exactly you've
become an actor of the future while I
don't have all the answers I'll offer
three guiding principles to help you
embrace professor Simon's philosophy
first be relentless in your pursuit of
knowledge being educated does not simply
mean getting a degree and then sitting
back rather it requires that you
constantly rekindle the fire of your
curiosity and stay engaged in the
evolution of new ideas do not be afraid
to expand your horizons when the
landscape shifts beneath you make the
world your classroom your canvas and
your stage told you is gonna be short
too second seek out perspectives other
than your own by exploring different
identities and experiences you will
create better ideas and stronger
solutions all along the way you will
encounter ideas that challenge you even
if you consider those ideas wrong or
even offensive the remedy is not less
conversation but more
ideas are not defeated by suppression
they're defeated by better more
persuasive ideas I urge you to embrace
and defend the free exchange of ideas
this is the foundation of our democracy
my third piece of advice brings the
previous two together the global
citizens thinking and acting globally is
not something that can be taught but
rather a mindset that's developed and
cultivated over a lifetime being a
global citizen means adopting a wide
view of the world and your role in it
it means thinking critically acting
entrepreneurial working collaboratively
and responding with empathy and
responsibility to humanity's most
pressing challenges global citizenship
also depends on deep understanding of
the connections that linked us to one
another think about all the people that
have contributed to your success today
whether directly or indirectly yes the
professors coaches directors advisors
friends and family members but also the
philanthropists like David Tepper who
chose to invest in generations of
students like you don't forget to enrich
the lives of others in the same way and
create opportunities for those who
follow you class of 2018 you all possess
the training and intellect to be
impactful actors of the future I am
truly excited for you and I'm excited
for the future which you hold in your
hands thank you for allowing me to share
this moment with you
and on behalf of the entire CMU
community congratulations class of 2018
we will conclude today's ceremony by
singing the alma mater with the vocal
performance of the class of 2018 we
invite you to please rise and sing along
the words who our alma mater can be
found in your program after we sing we
remain standing for the recession thank
you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
what I got
[Music]
[Applause]
they're delicious
[Music]
what pin yes finally
or something he was very front
we've had fun I see you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey no Sun the others
[Music]
[Applause]